dan domenech is the executive director
of the American Association of School
Administrators he's leading a task force
that is assisting schools all around the
country with their plans to reopen
safely he joins us now good morning to
you sir you know the stakes could not be
higher here we heard some teachers talk
about how it's a life-or-death choice
for them going back to the classroom so
how are you advising schools to weigh
the benefit of in-school instruction
against that risk that could really be
catastrophic well good morning Tony and
absolutely we have been talking to
superintendents from all over the
country for the last couple of months
trying to come up with how to reopen
schools safely and that is the primary
concern safety so we are concerned about
the safety of the students but also the
safety of the staff so we have a number
of plans and you're seeing that
happening right now in terms of what
districts have announced is going to
happen when school opens there are
basically three plans the one is to come
back as if nothing has happened which by
the way some districts are considering
and I don't know why the second one is
this hybrid model where basically
students come in for a couple of days a
week than their home so that this way
you can try to get to all of the kids in
the building and the third one which
we're also beginning to see particularly
in districts around this Washington DC
area and other parts of the country is
that it's not safe yet and therefore
remote learning is going to continue but
safety is the primary factor we're using
the CDC guidelines primarily in terms of
outlining for us what is safe we want to
make sure students are safe and we want
to make sure that staff is safe yeah dan
in those three categories that you just
outlined I'm curious with the tens of
millions of students all around the
country waiting for an outcome what
who's in what category and how big are
the three categories like how many
states and school districts might be
going back with very few precautions how
many in that middle position and how
many not going back at all it's
interesting Tony how things are changing
I can tell you that a month ago in
talking to many of our colleagues along
the southern belt states at that point
they were considering in just opening
schools or come on
all in many cases without any
precautions in terms of spacing or
facemask that's beginning to change now
and we're beginning to see even
governor's in those states like Kansas
is an example indicating that face masks
are mandatory postponing the opening of
schools the primary thing here is you
want to open schools according to what
was faced to from the whites a couple of
months ago and that is when the epidemic
the rate of infection is going down not
going on that's and when you do that
that you have the social spacing and all
the other precautions yeah but there may
be only there most states right now have
are either stable or going up in case
count so if we go by that that indicator
I mean most places are not going to open
I have a question from Jessica in
Indiana a viewer who also believed as a
teacher and she wants to know simply why
are we even talking about going to the
classroom at all why sacrifice in her
view the health of teachers and students
and maybe families when elearning is an
option it is an option and you're seeing
more and more districts doing that
announcing that that they are going to
open but remotely the key thing here are
the conditions the rate of the epidemic
in that community if it's going up you
don't want to open if it is going down
if it's minimal if things are being are
stabilizing then opening following the
precautions listed by the CDC are
important that six feet spacing between
children wearing of masks and all of
those other factors so it really has to
be determined by the community but it
has to be when it's safe to open not the
condition would that we see in many
states were the infection rate is
sky-high
yeah if schools make the investment to
change the environment and reopen and
then they get a case does that mean they
shut down completely what happens then
absolutely that's what the guidelines
say if there's a case in the building of
student or staff we're more than that
that building has to shut down it has to
be sanitized and it has to be a period
of time before the schools can come back
so you can almost predict that when
schools do open even with the safest of
precautions the minute there's the case
they're going to have to shut down again
I want to get in a question from Tabitha
Ross Roy who happens to be the Teacher
of the Year this past year and she says
look we know things gonna be different
but what can teachers do to help
students feel like this is a normal year
in some sense well you know what I don't
think there's any way you can help
students feel that this is a normal year
because it's not but the reality is that
these children these students have gone
through a lot of issues stress problems
and first and foremost the teachers have
to deal with that they have to talk to
their students they have to make sure
that they're comfortable they have to
hear their issues and their problems yes
there's been academic loss there's been
learning loss no question about that
but first and foremost in addition to
the safety and welfare of the students
is their emotional status and teachers
do a very good job in doing that yeah
they sure do and we should remind our
viewers that this is not a federal
decision it is a state and local
decision right down to the level of the
school district dan Dominic thank you
very much for walking us through your
position